una marioneta del socialismo así
calificó el presidente de donald trump a
su rival demócrata joe biden durante
todo el verano bayrén guardó silencio
mientras los vándalos de la extrema
izquierda atacaron brutalmente a las
fuerzas del orden en todas las ciudades
controladas por los demócratas
incendiaron negocios aterrorizaron a los
civiles
maiden nunca podrá proteger sus trabajos
ni a su familia es un títere de los
socialistas marxistas extremistas que
odian a los policías
las declaraciones del mandatario se
presentan luego de que vaivén viajara
wisconsin se reuniera con la familia del
joven afroamericano jake blake quien
quedó paralizado tras varios disparos de
un agente blanco y pidiera que se evite
la violencia
nada justifica los saqueos los incendios
o cualquier otra cosa por lo tanto
independientemente de lo enojado que
esté si alguien saque ao quema debe
rendir cuentas como alguien que hace
cualquier otra cosa punto el viaje de
bailén despertó una oleada de críticas
contra el mandatario que estuvo en la
ciudad de que no sea el martes pasado
pero no mencionó a blake y sólo mostró
su apoyo a los comercios afectados en
medio de las protestas contra el racismo
y la brutalidad policial impulsadas tras
lo ocurrido con blake en las últimas
semanas el mandatario se ha ponderado
como el único candidato capaz de
mantener la ley y el orden en el país
sin embargo su favorabilidad se
encuentra en jaque por la crisis del
cobi y el manejo de las protestas
precisamente este miércoles se conoció
un nuevo caso washington en el que un
policía le disparó a un afroamericano de
18 años quitándole la vida asimismo se
hizo público el caso de daniel frit un
hombre afro de 41 años que falleció
después de que
de la policía de rochester lo detuvieran
y le presionarán la cabeza contra el
pavimento los hechos ocurrieron en marzo
pasado